[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous mardi 24 octobre c'est
l'heure du 7-8 journal sur tv 78 tout de
suite les titres de cette édition la
mobilisation devant le siège de sodexo
ce matin à guyancourt
une trentaine de salariés est venue de
dreux en eure-et-loir ses employés
dénoncent la fermeture de leur usine
le groupe français de restauration
collective la juge non viables reportage
après les titres comme chaque mardi dans
le 7-8 journal le portrait de la
rédaction dédié à une personnalité
locale un portrait politique ce soir
consacrée à jean-michel fourgous le
maire d'elancourt et le tout nouveau
président de saint quentin en yvelines
retour sur son parcours et puis elle
s'implante à trappes positif planète
vient d'inaugurer sa première antenne
dans le sud yvelines la fondation aide
les personnes issues de quartiers
prioritaires a créé leur entreprise
nous en parlons à des cajuns morjane et
un responsable de bureau de positive
planète dans les yvelines
on prend la direction de guyancourt une
manifestation était organisée ce matin
devant le siège de sodexo
le leader français de la restauration
collective les salariés du site de dreux
en eure-et-loir sont venus protester
contre la fermeture de leur usine
construite en 2009 identifiées comme non
viable par la direction du groupe
reportage de mickeal et demi d'euros et
de patrick jacques de dixmude
[Musique]
beaucoup de bruit ce mardi 24 ans tom
autour du siège social de sodexo à lyon
pour une trentaine de salariés du site
de production de dreux est venue
protester contre la fermeture de leur
usine décision qui entraînera la
suppression de 62 postes d'ici la fin de
l'année
leur objectif aujourd'hui n'est plus de
sauver la structure mais de négocier au
mieux leur départ notre supra-légales
surtout parce que maintenant que quand
on sera licencié ben on voudrait fait
d'avoir quelque chose pour partir pour
redémarrer et nous à dreux sur sur la
ville de trou on n'a pas de travail du
tout donc on voudrait partir avec un
supra légale
quand même à la hauteur de ce qu'on
mérite donc voilà on est là c'est pour
battre et on lâchera pas en parallèle de
la manifestation une réunion s'est tenue
dans le siège de l'entreprise à
guyancourt avec les partenaires sociaux
et la direction
le but trouver des solutions trois
alternatives ont été proposées par le
leader français de la restauration
collective
la première c'est pas de leur proposer
un poste chez sodexo et llodra il ya des
propositions qui ont été faites
concrètement pour pour des reclassements
on a une deuxième piste 1 qu'est la
possibilité de voir le site être repris
par une société qui serait intéressé par
les locaux
on a des contacts très sérieux qui sont
en cours donc il ya cette perspective et
puis une troisième perspective qui est
l'accompagnement des collaborateurs qui
chuteraient mener un projet en dehors de
l'entreprise et pour lequel on peut les
accompagner dans la formation dans les
projets de reconversion
au total une quinzaine de postes
auraient été proposés par sodexo sur
d'autres sites une nouvelle réunion
pourrait être programmée la semaine
prochaine entre les parties c'est la
situation n'évolue pas les manifestants
ont déjà prévu de reconduire leur
mouvement dans les yvelines
politique les jeunes avec macron faisait
leur rentrée le week-end dernier partout
en france ils ont organisé des
interphones pour discuter de leur
contribution au projet de transformation
du pays portées par la république en
marche
en ile de france ça se passait dans les
yvelines à saint germain en laye plus de
250 personnes y ont assisté
au programme des débats thématiques
simulation deux séances à l'assemblée
nationale en présence d'élus béatrice
piron natalia plaisir f député des
yvelines entre autres et des
représentants nationaux comme le porte
parole du gouvernement
christophe castaner ainsi que mounir
mahjoubi
secrétaire d'état chargé du numérique on
passe à notre portrait de la semaine
chaque mardi nous mettons en lumière une
personnalité locale focus ce soir sur le
tout nouveau président de saint quentin
en yvelines jean michel fourgous qui est
également le maire d'elancourt retour
sur 25 ans de carrière politique et
économique avec nicolas kirillovitch
bonjour je suis le maire bonjour je suis
le maire de la ville était député ah bah
voilà une bonne mémoire même un dimanche
matin jean-michel fourgous fraîchement
élu président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines reste un homme
politique qui aime parler de chiffres
d'argent public et d'économie l'un pays
qui perd près de 100 milliards par an et
les mesures qui vaut rejet sont fortes
si on les prend pas et c'est dur à
prendre des mesures fortes ou pas jean
michel fourgous applique en tout cas des
mesures politiques depuis 25 ans et son
premier mandat en 1993 le docteur en
psychologie et diplômé de l'institut
d'études politiques de paris créé la
surprise et ravie alors à la gauche la
11e circonscription des yvelines
à 10h15 la sentence tombe elancourt
ville depuis longtemps conquise à guy
malandain passe à droite
un symbole puisque jean michel fourgous
bas guy malandain 2 43 voix
trois ans plus tard en 1996 jean michel
fourgous remporte cette fois ci les
élections municipales à elancourt face
au parti socialiste il sera réélu trois
fois et même dès le premier tour en 2008
et 2014
ses ambitions nationales elles
connaissent des coups d'arrêt successifs
avec plusieurs défaites en 1997 ou 2012
face au ministre socialiste benoît hamon
je tiens à rappeler quand même que
monsieur benoît hamon a bénéficié d'une
inégalité de traitement devant les
médias qui hors norme
bon donc j'assume le résultat je lui
souhaite bon courage et jeu et je
félicite la gauche qui a quand même
gagné ce soir
considéré par ses opposants politiques
comme clivant jean michel fourgous et en
tout cas fidèle depuis 25 ans à son
parcours d'entrepreneur le développement
économique et le thème essentiel de son
discours politique mais je crois que la
meilleure chose c'est de retrouver à nos
jeunes qui sont quelque peu en
difficulté d'en retrouver un emploi
ce sont les meilleures conditions parce
que quand ils sont au travail mais ils
font pas le zouave dans la rue et je
crois que
je crois que c'est aussi une de nos
priorités essentielles il faut
revaloriser le travail
faut arrêter de dévaloriser faut arrêter
de dire aux jeunes que il est normal de
se droguer lors qu'il faut penser à
moins travailler gens pendant ce temps
là vous sur les retraites sont pas
garantis la sécurité n'est plus garantie
de la protection sociale qu'est la
retraite n'est plus 40 reste sur place
que l'on soit attractif qu'on arrête de
déclarer cette guerre aux entrepreneurs
vous investisseurs comme on le fait
actuellement
il faut se réconcilier avec le monde
dans notre pays sinon on va perdre une
grosse partie de nos emplois
cette passion pour le monde économique
s'explique en partie par sa scolarité
mauvais élève jean michel fourgous
quitte l'école à 16 ans avant d'y
retourner quelques années plus tard
fasciné alors par le développement de
l'informatique
le fait de boire de diplômes au début ça
vous à ça vous oblige ça rend
intelligent de ces mêmes des deux
pauvres ou de ne pas des poseurs de
diplômes
ça vous rend intelligent obligé de
chercher des solutions sans faire appel
à la méthode qu'on vous donne après dans
des grandes écoles
donc j'ai commencé par là puis après mon
j'ai repris quelques études mais tout
cela je pense n'est pas sans rapport
avec le fait que j'ai eu envie de faire
de la politique
désormais président de saint quentin en
yvelines à 64 ans jean michel fourgous
souhaite réconcilier droite et gauche
pour notamment assurer le développement
économique de l'agglomération et en
faire une vitrine de l'innovation
c'est un véritable tremblement de terre
hashtag balances ton port multiples
témoignages accablants dernier en date
celui contre le producteur québécois
gilbert rozon accusé d'agression
sexuelle la révélation de la sphère
veinstein à créer un effet boule de
neige
et depuis la parution de l'article à
charge sur le producteur hollywoodien
dans le new york times en date du 5
octobre
de nombreuses femmes victimes de
harcèlement d'agressions sexuelles ou de
viols hausse par les ailes à paroles
semblent davantage libéré brisant
l'omerta bonsoir anne claude ambroise
rendu en soit merci d'être avec nous au
professeur d'histoire contemporaine à
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines vous intéresser
particulièrement à l'histoire de la
pédophilie au 19e et 20e siècles alors
harvey weinstein est accusé par une
dizaine d'actrices femmes du monde du
cinéma de viol d'attouchements ou encore
à d'harcèlement sexuel et témoignages
laissent apparaître que beaucoup de
personnes étaient au courant des
agissements du producteur sans les
dénoncé l'une des victimes d'ailleurs
l'actrice française léa seydoux a dit à
ce propos
difficile de dire non car il est
tellement puissance ce cas de figure ce
cas d' omerta est il finalement
similaire à celui d'une famille où un
enfant victime de pédophilie est victime
d'un inceste va avoir du mal à en parler
face à la figure imposante du père la
figure patriarcale de la famille oui je
crois que le ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui l'omerta c'est effectivement
la règle qui définit et qui rend
possible ce genre d'agissements et ceci
depuis
en tout cas pour pour ce que j'en sais
depuis le début du 19e siècle c'est à
dire que c'est un cet événement là est
un peut être le dernier épisode d'une
histoire du genre d'une histoire des
rapports entre les sexes que ça passe
par des violences faites aux enfants ou
faites à des femmes et c'est cette
histoire là a été placé originellement
sous le signe du silence et parce que ce
silence est rendue possible à la fois
par des relations de pouvoir et par
lala le développement chez la victime
j'utiliserai ce terme pour l'instant la
victime d'un sentiment de culpabilité
pendant longtemps la victime a pu se
sentir aussi coupables les femmes
pouvaient se sentir coupable de viol at
war alors les femmes se sentent est
coupable mais ça c'est céder pendant
précisément de ce rapport entre les
sexes parce que tant que les femmes se
sont elles mêmes vécu et ont intériorisé
cette représentation la dell comme décor
à disposition des personnes et où des
corps à disposition de des hommes et
bien évidemment elle ne pouvait que se
sentir coupable eq intégrer cette
dimension là après tout si je suis
l'objet de propositions avancées ou de
gestes déplacés ou de violence c'est
parce que il ya une espèce de fatalité
voilà c'est que d'une façon ou d'une
autre je les chercher et moi j'ai grandi
un peu sous cette danse est dans cette
représentation lac mais aujourd'hui
encore on sent un certain malaise c'est
des choses aussi de très présents encore
aujourd'hui alors oui je en croire les
témoignages
évidemment oui c'est quelque chose de
deux très présent lors particulièrement
singulièrement dans des relations dans
le cadre de relations qui sont des
relations professionnelles des relations
de pouvoir l'homme en place l'homme au
pouvoir étant celui par lequel on on a
quelques chances d'arriver à faire ce
qu'on veut et c'est donc évidemment
c'est une au fond vous faut il exerce un
double pouvoir à la fois à pouvoir sur
les corps pouvoir sur la sexualité et
puis un pouvoir professionnelle et donc
c'est une raison pour avoir du mal à lui
dire on doit avoir du mal à leur opposer
une résistance 1 et c'est une raison
pour avoir du mal ensuite à dénoncer ces
agissements comme étant quelque chose
d'inacceptable
parce que je pense que le set cette
notion d' inacceptable elle commence
elle pas qu'elle commence d'émerger né à
la tall à un point culminant co2
du côté du harcèlement donc difficulté
pour les victimes d'en parler vous le
dites il ya aussi beaucoup de personnes
qui semblait au courant des agissements
d' harvey weinstein tout comme ceux de
gilbert rozon dont l'affairé est plus
récente
il était au courant de ses agissements
mais ils n'ont rien dit comment on peut
expliquer aussi qui est cette forme de
loi du silence
est-ce qu'on peut aussi rapporter ça par
exemple à des êtres des intérêts qui
sont en jeu là la peur de perdre quelque
chose il perdrait quelque chose dans
l'histoire je crains qu'il y ait aussi
de dans l'esprit beaucoup d'hommes de
beaucoup d'hommes
l'idée est de certaines formes on l'a vu
récemment l idée qu après tout tout ça
n'est pas très grave
donc ça ne vaut pas vraiment la peine
parler parce que effectivement en parler
ça me met en jeu de tels intérêts et
c'est vrai aussi à l'intérieur de la
famille incestueuse ça met en jeu de
tels intérêts qui sont des intérêts
affectifs psychologique et matérielle
c'est tellement destructeur de cette
famille réel ou de cette famille
professionnels que par exemple le monde
d'hollywood que bon voilà les deux mis
dans la balance quelque chose qui somme
toute n'est pas considéré comme comme
bien grave
et cette destruction ira bon bah on se
tait serait qu on al impression qu
hollywood est une petite famille ou avec
ses secrets sa fonction voilà ça
fonctionne en grande partie comme une
famille et ça fonctionne d'ailleurs sur
des relations très ambigu qui sont des
relations de pouvoir et des relations
affectives aussi naturellement car c'est
l'omerta qui fait penser même si c'est
pas la même chose mais à des cas aussi
de par exemple de deux prêtres
pédophiles qui ont été longtemps passé
sous silence
on peut on peut aussi comparer à ça à
votre avis oui a toujours alors il ya
toujours s'il ya toujours cette question
du pouvoir du pouvoir qui est celui
détenu par l'agresseur et qui est un
pouvoir un pouvoir profond c'est à dire
qu'il ya un pouvoir matériel c'est un
adulte pour les prêtres pédophiles qui
exercent une autorité sur un enfant mais
il ya aussi un pouvoir moral spirituel
psychologique très fort et donc auquel
il est très difficile de résister et
chez beaucoup d'enfants victimes de
prêtres pédophiles
notamment il ya eu
on voit danser un certain nombre de
témoignages
l'idée pendant longtemps comme
d'ailleurs chez les enfants de père
incestueux l'idée que tout ça n'a pas
l'air très normal mais peut-être ça
allait quand même puisque le l'agresseur
et est une référence pour l'enfant alors
depuis la révélation de l'affairé on l'a
dit un vrai effet boule de neige
beaucoup de témoignages notamment le
hashtag balances ton porte sur twitter
qui incite les femmes à dénoncer leur
agresseur vous en avez déjà un peu parlé
dans cet entretien mais elle vous le
sentiment que la parole est davantage
libéré aujourd'hui
oui elle se libère elle se libère depuis
en gros les enfin bon ce qui concerne la
france mais aussi en grande partie pour
ce qui concerne les états unis ya un
premier temps de la libération dans les
années 1960 et 70 on l'a vu autour du
combat féministe et de la
requalification du violet de la loi de
décembre 1980 pour la france on a vu
voilà des les féministes les femmes
au-delà des féministes et des femmes qui
avaient été victimes justement dire non
ce n est plus possible et il faut que
ceux-ci soient sanctionnés réellement
est réel ou simplement par par la loi
mais ce qu'on constate à la faveur de
des événements récents c'est qu'en
réalité le temps de la libération de la
parole c'est un temps long parce que
c'est difficile pour les raisons qu'on
vient d'évoquer et que et qu'en plus
cette dénonciation là elle se elle se
déplaçait les parties du viol est elle
arrive maintenant à la question du
harcèlement ce qui est autre chose et il
faut quand même pas mélanger les deux il
faut pas faire d'amalgamé
même si c'est un mot je n'aime pas
utiliser parce que le viol l'agression
aux yeux du du du code pénal ça signifie
quelque chose le harcèlement en milieu
professionnel aussi bon puisque il faut
continuer à judiciariser à judiciariser
les rapports homme-femme et inventer de
nouvelles qualifications pour désigner
des formes de harcèlement dans d'autres
espaces que l'espace professionnel ça
c'est une question politique mais
d'autres questions qui se soulèvent on
l'a compris mercier a beaucoup anne
claude brazeau rendu est d'avoir été
avec tout je le rappelle vous êtes
professeur d'histoire contemporaine à
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines est les chiffres viennent
d'être révélées bonne nouvelle pour le
département le chômage a reculé le mois
dernier une baisse de 3 % pour la
catégorie à fin septembre on aiderait à
64 1880 demandeurs d'emploi dans les
yvelines en catégorie à temps dans ce
fidèle au niveau régional ou la baisse
est de 1,6 pour cent
c'est un espace dédié à l'innovation et
l'entrepreneuriat le ski tube a ouvert
ses portes en décembre 2016 et permis
d'accompagner et 12 start up à saint
quentin en yvelines
objectif booster leur développement
l'incubateur relance sa campagne de
recrutement et les nouveaux talents
futurs entrepreneurs et projets
innovants peuvent se porter candidat
jusqu'au 15 novembre prochain
le ski cube vous permettra de passer de
votre idée initiale un projet structuré
grâce à des conseillers sur place plus
d'informations sur le site internet sky
entreprise.com installation officielle à
trappes vendredi dernier positive
planète vient d'inaugurer sa première
antenne dans le sud des yvelines à la
fondation créée par l'économiste jacques
attali aide les personnes issues de
quartiers prioritaires à créer leur
entreprise bonsoir hager hager morjane
et merci d'être avec nous vous êtes la
responsable de bureau à 'positive'
planète yvelines l'eau angie est
implanté dans le département depuis 2012
des locaux aux mureaux à mantes la ville
et mantes la jolie
on en parle dans un instant de cette
arrivée à trappes revenons d'abord sur
l'historique de positif planète
le groupe a été créé en 1998 par jacques
attali l'association positive planète
france elle est est né en mai 2006 et
c'est à la suite
en fait si on rappelle les choses c'est
à la suite des émeutes en banlieue de
oui bonsoir donc effectivement posé six
planètes a été mis en place par jacques
attali ont fondé en 2006 suite aux
émeutes continuent à clichy notre
principale mission c'est de lutter
contre la précarité et l'exclusion dans
les quartiers en favorisant le goût
d'entreprendre
c'est comment vous y parvenez justement
qu'est ce que vous mettez en place pour
ça déjà de par nos implantations comme
vous l'avez dit rap est notre première
antenne sur le sud yvelines on a
aujourd'hui plusieurs antennes sur le
nord yvelines et c'est le fait d'être
implantés dans les quartiers qui nous
permet aujourd'hui de sensibiliser ces
publics fragiles donc qui sont très
éloignées de l'emploi dans le parcours
de création d'entreprise pourquoi c'est
important de d'agir justement dans ces
quartiers prioritaires parce que c'est
les personnes qui sont aujourd'hui comme
j'ai dit tout à l'heure les plus
éloignées de l'emploi qui retrouve pas
forcément de poste qui correspond à ce
qu'ils veulent faire et la création
d'entreprise est aujourd'hui une
alternative à l'emploi l'idée c'est
aussi de montrer que la banlieue a du
talent malgré ce qu'on peut entendre
parfois c'est de montrer que la banlieue
a du talent on exactement ce que c'est
vrai que là sur l'antenne de deux fois
ci on est implanté depuis fin 2012 et
aujourd'hui on compte environ 200
entreprises créées uniquement sur ce
territoire là et c'est des entreprises
avec différents statuts juridiques avec
différentes prestations de services et
qui prouve aujourd'hui avec le taux de
pérennité qu'ont acquis et de plus de 70
% qu'elles sont pérennes dans le temps
donc on arrive à démontrer aujourd'hui
en tout cas que entreprendre dans les
banlieues c'est possible alors positif
l'année vous l'avez dit on y dans les
yvelines est présent donc depuis 2012
la première antenne a été ouverte dans
le sud yvelines ça c'était vendredi
dernier c'était l'inauguration
officielle d'ailleurs à trappes
pourquoi oui ça ne s'est pas fait avant
2012 la wii on en arrive en 2010 est
pourquoi attendre autant de temps
finalement pour s'implanter dans le sud
yvelines
c'est vrai que on a beaucoup travaillé
sur le north yvin on avait besoin
d'avoir une notoriété on avait besoin
d'être reconnu en tant qu'acteur de la
création d'entreprise
aujourd'hui c'est fait le sud yvelines
ça a été aussi une demande on s'est
rendu compte qu'il y avait un réel
potentiel puisqu'il ya quand même des
personnes du sud yvelines qui venaient
nous voir jusqu'à précis pour être
accompagnés pour leur projet de création
d'entreprise
du coup on a fait une étude d'impact qui
a permis aujourd'hui de valider cette
ouverture à trappes dans l'un des plus
grands quartiers du film donc justement
et qu'est ce qui a motivé devenir
attrape précisément mais après c'est
vrai que nos implantations sont faits un
peu de manière stratégique
on essaie de ne pas ouvrir des antennes
partout on essaie de les ouvrir vraiment
dans des zones qui en ont besoin
aujourd'hui le quartier des musées en a
besoin il ya un réel potentiel dessus et
c'est la raison pour laquelle on a
ouvert
à trappes pour trappe et on imagine
aussi pour tous les futurs entrepreneurs
de risques quand en yvelines exactement
tout à fait alors comment ça se passe
concrètement quand une personne vient
vous voir vient solliciter l'aide de
positif planète
alors en fait on les accompagne de
manière individuelle
étape par étape qui partent de l'idée et
qui passe par ski études de marché
stratégie commerciale prévisions
financières recherche de financement
avec des partenaires financiers jusqu'à
la création
on fait également un suivi post création
jusqu'à trois ans et recevoir votre aide
ça marche vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
et man sam après son père m exactement
aujourd'hui on a un taux de pérennité de
comme j'ai dit à l'air depuis de 70%
on a des entreprises qui ne sollicitent
des porteurs de projets qui nous
sollicitent aussi on a une notoriété sur
comme j'ai dit alors sur le nom yvelines
et on espère avoir la même sur les
subsides les dernières choses on l'a dit
les locaux inaugurés vendredi dernier
quels sont vos objectifs la sueur trappe
qu'est ce que vous espérez de cette
nouvelle implantation d'accompagner un
maximum de porteurs de projets issus des
quartiers leur permettent de retrouver
une situation stable et être autonome
financièrement et sortir de cette
précarité
merci à jaar morjane et d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle vous êtes un
responsable du bureau positive planète
france dans les yvelines l'association
elle vient de lancer sa première antenne
je le rappelle dans le sud yvelines
c'est à trappes
plus d'informations sur le site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran un
événement culturel et solidaire ce
dimanche c'est une après-midi de concert
organisé par le lions club de
rambouillet autour de la guitare est le
rendez vous est au profit des personnes
âgées des malades ou personnes
handicapées mais également en faveur
d'associations humanitaires qui agissent
notamment dans des villages du cameroun
mélanie poquet
[Musique]
à terme ans qui vagabonde
faber en sera la tête d'affiché ce jeune
rangoly temps à accepter de jouer au
deuxième concert guitare et solidarité
une après-midi organisé par le lion's
club de rambouillet on va s'amuser en
même temps on peut aider donc pas
d'hésitation j'écoute beaucoup de
musique anglo saxonne comme justement la
fois le corps landaise comme damian rice
ou des choses beaucoup plus populaires
comme jason mraz
j'aime bien les sonorités et puis écrire
en français sur ce type de musique
évidemment souchon c'est un voilà c'est
un exemple comme en terme d'écriture
[Musique]
mais
le 29 octobre quatre heures de concert
joue aussi caroline bio marie platel les
élèves de l'école de musique d'elancourt
ou encore le duo cadet clem autour d'un
seul instrument la guitare
les guitares c'est un instrument
international populaire facile à
transporter qui a été sur tous les
continents l'afrique l'europe l'amérique
du sud l'asie on joue de la guitare par
tous c'est un langage international
l'objectif est douce et de permettre à
des d'une part permettent à des jeunes
talents de s'exprimer mais aussi à des
des retraités qui joue très bien qu'ils
cherchent des chaînes des scènes et
aussi de surtout collecter des fonds les
fonds iront à des actions sociales et
humanitaires
l'an dernier le lion's club avait
récolté près de 3000 euros
ce sont en ce moment les vacances de la
toussaint et pourquoi pas en profiter
pour découvrir le patrimoine yvelinois
elle nous vous emmenons au musée
national de port royal des champs situés
à magny les hameaux
il est installé sur le site d'une
ancienne abbaye sur place une collection
de gravures de livres de livres anciens
deux portraits et des ouvrages qui
témoigne de l'histoire des lieux
reportage de mathilde denis blaise
pascal ou encore jean racine sy sont
promenés port royal des champs en seine
l'abbaye fondée au xiiie siècle un lieu
historique à visiter à magny les hameaux
orwell deschamps aujourd'hui c'est
d'avoir un très grand site de 30
hectares dans lequel on peut avoir
d'abord bien sûr le site des ruines de
l'abbaye de grands jardins
avec l'ancien verger construit par les
messieurs de port royal au xviie siècle
où les jardins que pouvait avoir le
fermier qui ont été reconstituées c'est
un grand parc dans lequel on peut
prendre du temps se promener descendre
par les allées dans une sorte de sous
bois le long de la long de la vallée ou
suivre une partie de la rivière
lorsqu'on est sur le site de l'abbaye
des vestiges d'une époque qui ont été
gravées sur la toile par de nombreux
artistes un lieu qui raconte son
histoire à travers l'architecturé l'art
au royal c'est aussi un musée national
qui conserve un certain nombre de
peintures très importante du xviie
siècle la plupart exécuté par un grand
peintre qui est vive de champaigne tous
ces tableaux ont été peints dans les
année ses 150 160 pour l'abbaye pour
être minorée de mise pour être mis dans
les bâtiments et on peut toujours les
voir aujourd'hui de laval et
l'emplacement des vignes donc il ya
quelques lignes qui ont été replantés
ici et pour guy roux vite qu'on avait
les vignes au 17e port royal des champs
un musée national gratuit jusqu'à 26 ans
et qui vous accueillera lors des
journées du patrimoine le 16 et 17
septembre à l'occasion des journées du
patrimoine le public peut rentrer dans
l'oratoire qui se trouve sur le site de
l'abbaye
ce petit oratoire 19e siècle est fermé
depuis 30 ans il est habituellement
fermés au public
on aura la possibilité de le découvrir
pendant les journées du patrimoine
avant que nous puissions commencer
les travaux de rénovation et de
restauration de ce monument un musée
national qui devrait s'agrandir pour
accueillir de nouvelles toiles et qui se
donne un coup de jeune pour survivre à
toutes ces époques
avant de se quitter demain c'est le jour
des sorties au cinéma vous retrouverez
notamment la comédie épouse moi mon pote
réalisé par tarek boudali et avec
philippe lachaux les deux compères que
l'on a connu dans baby sitting était à
l'ugc et skywest hier pour en faire la
promotion l'histoire un jeune marocain
étudiants france perd son visa à la
suite d'un examen raté il demande alors
à son amie de l'épousé pour obtenir la
nationalité française
les choses vont bien évidemment se
compliquer thématique donc sérieuse mais
traitée sous le trait de l'humour
l'image de nicolas kirilow dit c'est la
fin de ce set 8 journal reportages et
replay à retrouver sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile tv
78 excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]